pues Raúl muy buenos días tardes acá en
davos y con un clima que le cuento que
estaba bastante bueno menos cuatro
grados o menos tres grados pues mire
empezó entonces este congreso con los
discursos de Úrsula fonder Legend Pero
antes y del viceministro chino liuji
pero Antes hubo un mensaje bastante
sentido de la primera dama ucraniana
quien aseguró que buscan ganarle esta
guerra a Rusia en algún momento con la
ayuda de todos los países por su parte
la presidenta de la comisión europea
basó su discurso en tres cosas primero
en reiterar el apoyo de Ucrania dijo que
este año se van a destinar en total
18,000 millones de euros para este país
lo segundo fue su su discurso estuvo
dirigido a Rusia diciendo que pues ya
reemplazaron el 80% del gas que venía de
este país pero adicionalmente dio
bastantes dardos a China como usted lo
decía dijo que este país está
subvencionando a las compañías que se
vayan hasta esta nación y consuman
energía masivamente y esto pues está por
supuesto debilitando los planes que
tiene la Unión Europea para precisamente
hacer esa transición energética entonces
lo que dijo Es que habrá un mensaje
contundente para china en el caso de que
siga haciendo o que siga digamos
generando que las compañías se vayan
para allá consumir más energía china por
su parte el discurso del Primer Ministro
liuji estuvo basado en la economía en
general no hubo un mensaje directo de
respuesta a úrsulada fonder Legend Pero
lo que sí dijo en lugar de entregar un
mensaje directo lo que sí dijo Es que
necesitan inversión privada y que no
quieren una economía de compañías
controladas por el estado y por eso es
que precisamente se están entregando
todas estas subvenciones Dani le
pregunta además que se espera en la
agenda para toda esta semana
pues Raúl mire hoy es el Día de los
grandes discursos va a haber unas
conferencias con los principales
asistentes a esta conferencia por
ejemplo viene el presidente de Colombia
Gustavo Petro quien va a liderar un
panel sobre cambio climático y también
en el que va a hablar de la paz total en
Colombia viene también el presidente de
Ecuador Guillermo lasso En total son 52
los mandatarios que van a estar acá esta
semana 18
gobernadores de banco centrales de todo
el mundo Así que se espera pues una
agenda bien nutrida con temas que van
desde por supuesto la economía los
vientos de recesión pasando también por
el cambio climático inclusive hay un hay
un panel bien atractivo sobre Brasil y
la amazonía y la defensa de la amazonía
y también hay otros sobre
las mujeres los derechos de las mujeres
en Irán es una agenda bastante diversa
No solamente de temas económicos sino
también podríamos decir de temas
políticos y se espera también la llegada
del
jefe del gobierno español en los
próximos días